once upon a time in a land called
Washington lived a man named Adam Schiff
from his tower on the hill he spent
years trying to slay a dragon called
Donald Trump but then one day himself
ended up slain by a monster called
the truth newly released congressional
testimony shows that Adam Schiff spread
falsehoods shamelessly about Russia and
Donald Trump for three years even as his
own committee gathered contrary evidence
he misled the country repeatedly on an
issue that consumed American politics no
one should ever believe another word he
says as chairman of the House
Intelligence Committee Schiff led the
Russia Trump collusion probe back in
2017 over 14 months 50-plus witnesses
6,000 pages of testimony the content of
which has now come to light and guess
what no conspiracy in ur a Clinton just
lost these freshly released transcripts
reveal that top intelligence officials
who came in for questioning all tall
holes and ships very terrible conniving
Kremlin an untrustworthy Trump for
example remember when George papadopolis
was jailed
we have some breaking news out of
Washington former Trump campaign aide
George papadopolis has been sentenced to
14 days in jail well apparently even
back then the FBI director wasn't a
hundred percent convinced Papadopoulos
his comment didn't particularly indicate
that he was the person that had had that
was interacting with the Russians also
who could forget the infamous steel
dasya used by Russia Gators far and wide
a secret proof of meddling when you look
at just what has become public some of
the public information is very much in
line with what is reported in that
dossier you know well as I tried to
explain before there's a lot of
information in this steel reporting
we've not been able to prove the
accuracy of all the information in fact
the message from the transcripts is
overwhelmingly obvious I never saw any
direct empirical evidence that the Trump
campaign aware someone in it was
plotting or conspiring with the Russians
to meddle with the election I don't
recall intelligence that
consider evidence to that effect that I
saw prior of conspiracy prior to my
departure obvious to everyone apparently
except Schiff who continued to hop from
TV channel to TV channel weaving tales
he already you weren't true we do know
this
the Russians offered help the campaign
accept that help the Russians gave help
and the president made full use of that
help the bottom line is did the Russians
intervene in our election and the answer
is yes did they make outreach the Trump
campaign and the answer is yes and it's
not just that she actively misled the
public it's that he even tried to hide
the evidence
most of the transcripts were ready for
at least long ago but mr. Schiff oddly
refused to release them after he became
chairman in 2019 he only released them
last week when the White House
threatened to do it first I mean he did
make good use of that time he had the
transcripts even managing to squeeze in
an impeachment attempt which just like
his previous Kalusha probe and the new
report was a bust
little wonder then that the president
feels vindicated
so was Trump kicks back in the Oval
Office he's probably pondering the irony
of ships words the truth will come out
the truth will come out
I think it's just an absolute or a
political earthquake there's no other
way to put it
over three years we see top officials
including Intelligence Committee
Chairman Adam Schiff the head of the NSA
at the time the the head of the CIA all
of them knew that there was no Russian
collusion yet they played along as if
there was they did investigations they
gave quotations they appeared and on all
too willing media shift claimed he went
on television and claimed that the
Russians offered to help Trump Trump
knew the Russians were offering to help
he accepted the Russians offer and the
Russians got him put into office he said
all of those things when he knew for a
fact based on all of the interviews that
he did with the people that were there
and involves he knew that it was
absolutely untrue yet he continued to
say it anyway and essentially the
attempt
was to overthrow a duly elected
president the United States whether we
like him or not it's immaterial
this was a coup attempt and now we know
what we suspected all along that it was
all made up and they knew it was made up
you